je vais tout cas shalit
j'avais formé en 1982 fait lexique
junior était numéro un mondial au box
office des jeux d'arcade mais
aujourd'hui les personnages des jeux
vidéo sont bien plus compliquées que
monde croyait nous vous révélons
d'histoires inédites du bichon qui est
au coeur de ce jeu sensationnel
nous vous invitons tous nos coûts 10 mai
monde de ralph le monde rencontrera la
casse dans le jeu félix fils junior
mais dans ce monde de 8 bits une journée
où travaillent les copains la vie
n'était pas fait de ce corps élevé et me
de bonus ap un mois ralph rêvait d'un
autre monde où il serait apprécié et
reconnu aimer
cela aurait pu être un calendrier une
danse de folie il mène un album de noël
hélas ce n'était pas ça tuer le méchant
qui démolit notre immeuble ce qu'a fait
rage
ensuite été si inattendue il a déserté
son propre jeu si stendhal eux c'est
contraire à toutes les règles
tu as des septs et ton jeu qui que les
studios disney sauter sur l'occasion
pour raconter son histoire
c'est ainsi que la ville de ralph allait
changer à tout jamais
soyez des hommes pour que votre maman
soit fier rejoignez nous dans les
coulisses du tournage en compagnie de kj
ouverte le personnage que personne ne
comprend qu'est ce que vous avez